[Music]
so uh why do I well first of all who am
I uh do you know this thing called
pytorch um a lot of people in AI used to
know it but now a lot of people just use
high level apis and don't know what's
powering things underneath uh but like
py is uh the software probably powering
your AI apis um so I work on it I
co-founded the project and it's uh it's
a big project that is uh majority funded
by meta where I work at um and so I'm
talking about uh so I'm not talking
about llama at all I work on llama a
little bit but uh
unfortunately uh am not in charge of
llama to try to sneak in some secrets
for you guys um I'm not going to tell
you when the next llama is going to come
or anything like that so uh why am I
thinking about personal local agents
well the as AI kind of started becoming
more and more useful one of the things
that saved my time the most every single
day was swix is AI news and it's
basically like I have to keep up to date
with all of what's going on in AI That's
my job and now instead of basically
spending 3 four five hours a day um
looking at a bunch of sources like they
was aggregating a bunch of news for you
and I thought that was like one of the
like one of the first applications I
thought was like
mind-blowingly uh personally like
effective for my own productivity and
that's when I started going into like
hey I'm going to like augment uh AI
within my day-to-day
in a deeper way um that's not an agent
though AI news is more like a an
aggregator uh but that's how it kind of
started the other thing is I also work
on robotics um and robots are
essentially agents they act in the world
so um I I my goal is to build home
robots so that I don't need to do any
errands um and so um as part of that
Journey as well I've been like kind of
getting into like okay how do I get into
understanding AI agents more deeply um
the key takeaway I'm going to really
like drill down uh to you today is
Agents like especially personal agents
have so much POS agency in taking
actions on your behalf and stuff and
they have so much of your life context
to actually be useful to you that you're
better off keeping them local and
private and I'm going to try to like
sketch out a plan on how to do it but I
don't think I have a complete solution
either um so so first like agent what is
an agent like and why did I say swix is
AI news is not an agent well an agent is
something that can act in the world like
an agent is something that has agency it
can actually like take an action in the
world uh anything that can only get
context and do things but then
eventually can't act in the world is not
an agent that's how I think about it and
what I think is like a highly
intelligent agent without the right
context is as good as a bag of rocks
it's like really useless I'll give you a
couple of examples very quickly uh let's
just say I build a personal agent it has
uh access to my Gmail my WhatsApp my
calendar I was like did did I get my
prescription renewed and it's like no
not yet and like it's totally lying uh
except it didn't know because like I got
the text from CVS on my iMessage and it
didn't have access to uh that source and
it was doing the best it can with the
information it has but if it didn't have
the context like it's not going to like
know how to do better uh similarly I
mean you can make up like a 100 examples
like this where like you have access to
One bank account but like your money
came into a venmo and you're like uh the
agent lied to you what happens is like a
personal agent that doesn't have the
right context it's largely going to be
irritating to use it's like you don't
know when it is useful and when it is
not useful so it's essentially not
useful um like even when it gives you
some answer you're like H is this
actually right I'm going to have to go
dig in right so unless it hits a certain
level of like reliability and
predictability that you know it is right
uh it's not going to be actually useful
to you um so now like why am I talking
about personal agents specifically um
and how do you like how do you get all
this context to the agent so let's just
say you have like your open API or some
other API or some local llm what is all
the context in the world that is
personal to you and how do you give it
to the agent well like the number one
thing that you possibly want to do is
like just have variables right you're
just like you can uh the your AI should
see everything you see and listen to
everything you hear um and that is like
obviously the best case of providing
context to your AI AG except like
there's no battery life for any of these
variable things so that's not really
practical maybe one day when you have
like crazy batteries but that's not
really going to work the other thing
could be like okay like most of my life
is on my phone uh in the ways that I
care about from like an agent
perspective uh what about just like uh
running an agent on my phone it's
running the background and it's just
like always like watching my screen or
something well well you know that's
where like apple kicks you because you
know they don't let you run a bunch of
stuff in like on your phone
asynchronously if you even if you do
they have a lot of restrictions so like
the ecosystems kind of like kill you and
not allowing you to do that and
unfortunately I use like apple um so
that's that's out so the next one is
like okay actually like the thing that I
found like relatively useful is like if
you use like apple in your daily life uh
you can actually get a Mac Mini and like
just put it somewhere in your home
connect it to the internet and you can
run your agents asynchronously there's
no battery life issues you can just log
into all your services on your like Mac
Mini and um it also can access all the
Android ecosystems because Android is
actually open um
so I work at neither of these companies
I can say what I
want um so I I think that's like what I
think is a feasible um um device to use
to like run your AI agent right now um
the next thing I want to talk about is
like okay why are you talking about
local and private why can't you just
like run this in the cloud like just
subscribe to one of the large tech
companies uh agent services and run your
life out of it well I want to give you
like a few points here uh first is
um I want to talk about how this is
different from you using other Digital
Services and I think it is different
meaningfully and I think it's also easy
to understand so let's just think about
like a lot of you in this room probably
use like a cloud email service that is
free for all of your life all your taxes
are going in there like you know
everything personal is going in there
why do you trust it the reason I think
you trust it at least the reason I trust
it is because it has a very simple
mental model on how it will act on your
behalf or how it will act in general
email in reply out it's not um go it's
basically not trying to do something
sneaky under you that is unpredictable
it's a very simple mental model your
trust of that service is correlated with
whether you understand how it behaves on
your behalf so imagine tomorrow if some
unknown email service that you've been
using forever says oh you know for some
of your emails that I have confidence in
I can auto reply on your behalf and
you're like okay well first of all that
might be true but what is the worst case
action you can take maybe you'll like
reply to my boss like something nasty
and like I don't want that to happen and
like that's like once the action space
becomes powerful enough and
unpredictable enough you get
uncomfortable with using a service that
you're not fully in control um and it
can get like worse right like uh
companies have to monetize in a million
ways and so what if like you're
using like like an online service and
they suddenly are like oh you know every
time you ask for a shopping query we're
going to like start making the agent
only buy from like stuff that gives us
Kickbacks or something so like I think
like your personal is so personal to you
and so intimate that I feel like
ultimately you want to be in control uh
on many aspects that you might not have
control on eventually when you have to
like trust uh an online service so
that's like one of the biggest reasons
like why I feel I want to build a
personal agent that's local uh to myself
the second is decentralization like I
mean you already see all these
ecosystems that are wall Gardens and
like fighting with each other and don't
allow each other to interoperate in
various ways and if you build one of
like your personal life uh your personal
agent around one ecosystem like is that
something like it it works fine for
compartment L things like maps and email
and various things but like is that
something that you want to really
subscribe into for like an agent that
can take so many different kinds of
actions on your behalf uh in your
day-to-day life that's like the other
reason I I I feel like you should try to
we as a world should try to get to like
local personalized agents as the
norm um and the third one is um for
various reasons okay this is what I
called uh this is what I call um are you
going to be punished for your thought
crimes right like okay you have a
thought and it is not a good thought and
like you know should you be punished for
it and usually like the answer is no no
now if you have a personal agent that is
effectively augmenting you in such an
intimate personal way you might be
asking it stuff that you generally
wouldn't say out loud
ever um and in those cases like do you
really want to take the risk of like
like putting it out into like some
provider because like you know you you
can actually ask perplexity like
Enterprise grade Cloud API contracts
that like are like
um Enterprise not consumer grade where
they like get sloppy even they have to
like do a bunch of like legally mandated
logging and then safety checks and stuff
so there is a possibility that like you
might or might not want to take a risk
on but for me I'm like I don't want to
ever get into a scenario where like I
will be like prosecuted or persecuted
for my thought crimes and like that I
think is like another really powerful
argument for myself at least to focus on
like local agents for my most personal
um uh
augmentation so now coming to um well I
hope you're convinced that yes yes we
actually like if you're going to build a
personal AI agent it has to be local and
private uh well okay what's the problem
well let's go to the technical
challenges first first like okay you got
to run this stuff right um there are
like great open first projects to run a
bunch of local models that are one of
the key components of these agents VM
and SG Lang are pretty great uh they're
both built on top of
pytorch
so effectively uh this is one time like
we wrote a bug in pyge and um a bunch of
us uh had a Tesla car and Tesla uses
pytorch and we were like man like this
is so scary because like are we writing
bugs on ourselves that's an
aside uh it was totally fine the bug was
not that
bad um so yeah vill esang are great um
but local model inference is still as of
today slow and limited it's not as fast
as like you know if you just use like a
cloud service even if you spend like a
be like enough money on a beefy machine
I think that's also rapidly changing
like for example local Al if you're
using like a 20 billion or distilled
model of some sort it actually runs
pretty fast uh but if you want to use
like the latest R1 like full unquantized
then it runs like super duper damn slow
um I think this like is in a state of
like it will fix itself so you you
probably wouldn't get to run the latest
and
greatest um and I think like the
challenge are not so much the technical
and infrastructural challenges like they
will kind of get to a place where
they're fine I think there's some
challenges around like both the research
and product that um people need to think
a bit more about I think there's a bit
of a gap and this is just an open
challenge for this room for all of you
AI Engineers um one is like the open
multimodal models are good but not great
I mean they're not great in a couple
areas one is like just computer use
even the closed models like the latest
and greatest apis that you can just pay
money for they're not that great for
computer use they break all the time so
that needs to definitely get like into a
better State the other thing like I
noticed is like if I ask a model to do
shopping for me from clothes to shoes to
Furniture to whatever it'll basically
give me the most boring right like
it's like the basic stuff and if I ask
it if I'm like look I'll tell you my
tastes and my taste can get very like
specific and fine like the more specific
I get the more like it gives me
like it's like it's like the same oh you
asked for like a red velvet sofa with
Oak wooden
legs uh here's a green sofa that has
velvet um and it doesn't have like Oak
wooden legs you know like they're not
very good at identifying actually
visually what you're asking for they
mostly rely on like a bunch of text
matching um the other thing uh you will
notice and this is a big one is we don't
have good catastrophic action
classifiers what I what do I mean by
catastrophic actions
is there's many actions an agent can
take a lot of them are reversible or
harmless like even if it takes the
action and that's not the action you
wanted it to take it's like whatever oh
it had to go to like that particular
Wikipedia link but it went to this other
one okay big deal whatever it'll just
backtrack and go but there's some
actions that are actually catastrophic
for example you ask it to go purchase
like uh a renal of your Tide Pods and
then it goes and like purchases a Tesla
car you know this is not the best thing
for you to do uh and some of these are
called catastrophic actions and I don't
think there's a lot like there's some
open research around like how to really
get agents to get good at identifying
catastrophic actions before taking them
and then maybe like notifying the users
instead uh but there's not enough and so
if you want to really trust your agents
personal or in Cloud I think we got to
get a bit better at these
things um so that's like a big one and I
think open source voice mode is barely
there uh I feel like when I need a
personal local agent I definitely want
voice mode because sometimes I want to
talk to it uh and not actually type out
everything I want to say um but still
why am I bullish about this whole thing
I am uh because one I see open models
are actually like compounding an
intelligence like faster than closed
models like based on how many resources
are being put on them like what do I
mean by that like open AI is only
improving their own model anthropic is
only improving their own model with all
the billions they have or whatever but
open models are improving themselves
like in coordination across
board um and you know people didn't
really believe it until Lama came out
and they didn't they didn't really
believe it until mistol came out and
then they didn't really believe it until
guac came out uh and then they didn't
really believe it until deep sea came
out like basically like people are like
oh you know like open models you know
will not really win but I think they are
like basically open source like I've
work in open source like all my life um
there's a starting coordination problem
like initially you don't have enough of
a critical mass to coordinate with each
other but once you have a critical
coordinated Mass open source kind of
starts winning in like an unprecedented
way and you see that with Linux you see
that with a bunch of projects uh so I am
pretty bullish that open models would
actually start getting like better than
closed models um uh um like per dollar
of in investment into open models
um
and that's what I said well okay I have
some plugs uh this is like uh gr. in
from my friend Ross Taylor who worked on
this model called Galactica which got a
lot of like um criticism when it was
released uh out of meta it was this open
science model before Chad GPT released
now like doing science with like llms is
pretty common but like they got a lot of
when they released uh and he like
quit uh he like unreleased Galactica and
he quit doing like a bunch of stuff
publicly but then like he's working on
like plugging the the reasoning gap
between open models and closed models
and they released a bunch of open
reasoning data uh that will help so just
a nice quick plug the other quick plug
is I work on PCH pytorch is working on
enabling local agents especially the
technical challenges that I talked about
uh and we're hiring so if you are more
than an AI engineer if you're an AI
engineer who's also like a systems
engineer then like py is hiring
um well that's what we
got the other thing obviously is I
welcome you all to come to llama con
which is happening on April 29th and
save the date it's going to be very
exciting lots of llama stuff will happen
there that's it uh I think it's in
California I I actually didn't look it
up
[Music]